hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my arrow episode 1 video totally
back to season one quality totally love
the episode just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen it yet we finally found
out what laurels promise was and we got
a big deep cut for the list so I think
the list is very important for
Prometheus's character
like they're connected to someone who
Oliver killed just because Marc
Guggenheim the producers have said that
Oliver bears a measure of responsibility
in the creation of Prometheus so the big
left turn of the episode is that he's
killing again like he felt guilty for
not killing damian darhk-- when he had
the chance before he was able to kill
Laurel that's kind of like him returning
back to the pilot they kind of do the
same thing in the flash episode where
like they go back to the pilot episode
dropping bodies hardcore they even
killed somebody in that flash pilot -
and in the flash episode so two big
deaths in the CW DC universe this week
but all signs are pointing towards the
list being one of the big MacGuffins of
the season so we'll circle back around
to that but just think about all those
names that the Bratva read off the list
when he pulled it out of Oliver pocket
like right after they captured him so
let's do top 10 WTF and Easter eggs
number 10 is the way they open the
episode with Oliver seeming like he's
back to his old tricks
is it a blonde or red brunette actually
as it cuts to Oliver kickin the brunette
but of anarchy who's left like bombs all
over the city that Oliver has to disarm
the character anarchy obviously big deep
cut for last season so we know that he's
still around he'll probably pop back up
sometime during the season we meet Wilde
doc in a roundabout way Oliver just like
tells him to hit the bricks this whole
episode was kind of slowly intro a new
team arrow but we don't really meet them
till episode 2 next week you could also
consider that blonde or red joke as an
Oracle reference
just because Felicity has blonde hair in
for a while she was going to be the
Oracle character but then became
overwatch because the name quote-unquote
was already taken
that was kind of the sign that Batman is
definitely in the universe but number 9
was all the Neil Adam sketches probably
the most literal comic book stuff
happening there were a lot of comic book
moments that I'll talk about but the
most actual comic book moments were when
DC like long time
Green Arrow DC artist Neal Adams had a
bunch of sketches that they used in the
episode so there was a sketch of Oliver
there was a sketch of vigilante like
basically all the police sketches when
Felicity's like look at all these
vigilantes out there we need a new team
actually starts pointing to them those
are all Neal Adams originals that were
drawn specifically for this episode the
last one they held up was the Green
Arrow one so obviously it's the Oliver
version of Green Arrow this is what the
classic Neal Adams Green Arrow looks
like but number eight meet wild dog they
just brought him back in Green Arrow
rebirth there's like this wild dog
militia if you've been reading that so
the way they tease him is that his
superpower is guns in the comics he's
someone who inherits a lot of money
after people close to him die so he uses
that money to buy guns to fight them out
like he uses that money to fight the mob
so he's like the definition of DC
street-level hero who is very happy to
gun bad people down Punisher style so
because killing is back on the table so
to speak during arrow season five it'll
be interesting to see how they address
that because Oliver wants to kill again
wild dog is hardcore with the guns so
we'll see but obviously you expect them
to stop killing people by the end of the
season number seven is mayor Oliver
Queen marathoning West Wing to learn how
to be mayor he just treats it like a
complete joke it's totally funny the way
he talks about it in this episode I'm
using it to get Intel to help me as the
green arrow at night he's kind of doing
the same thing that iris West is doing
with Wally in the flashpoint timeline on
the flash so like she's using her
contacts as a reporter to source cases
for Wally to track down as the flash
Oliver has been using his time as mayor
to gain intel on criminals to take down
as the green arrow so the whole problem
here though is is that he's a one-man
team so he just doesn't have enough
hours in the day to do all the stuff he
needs to do as mayor and his Green Arrow
so that's why there's all the crap in
the paper about him speaking of which
number six he goes to see Quentin who's
fallen off the wagon where's Donna she's
in heaven it was an it was a nice joke
like there's no way they're gonna kill
Felicity's mom off off screen even if
you didn't like her character that would
still be a little upsetting like when
big stuff that should happen on-screen
happens off screen now relax evan is a
casino it just based
luckily them telling you that Quentin
has been pretty terrible the last couple
of months Marc Guggenheim joked that
their goal each season was to give
Quentin a new job the way Tom Cavanagh
comes back every year with the new
personality so they weren't able to do
that during season four but like the
first season he was a detective in
season two he became police captain then
he got suspended he was fired so now it
seems like this season he's going to be
liaises going to be working with that
special Crime Unit
they have like a special crime task
force that's going to report directly to
mayor Oliver Queen
that is totally down with helping
vigilantes I'm so happy that they're not
doing like the [ __ ] plot where the
police are always going after the good
guys like they're always going after
Green Arrow even though I think there's
going to be some problems because
Prometheus seems like he's undercutting
a lot of the stuff that Green Arrow's
doing people will mistake him for the
green arrow because he's wearing a
costume that looks very much like Oliver
season one costume but because of the
way the show works you kind of need to
address what's going on at the police
station so I believe that this is
Felicity's new boyfriend so like they're
good people in the police station they
won't be fighting Oliver but there is
the twist with Felicity's boyfriend so
we'll see how that works out and
prometheus killed one of them at the end
of the episode so already they're under
siege but number five old team arrow not
going to be coming back anytime soon
I mean Felicity's still in the arrow
cave mr. terrific is there so there are
aspects of old team arrow that are still
there but like Diggle isn't coming back
any time soon but he will come back and
Thea is like hard pass on being speedy
anymore but I don't think that's going
to stick either like that red costume
is just too cool looking to sit on a
shelf for a long time so eventually
there'll be a reason for her to pick it
back up again but all this old team
versus new team stuff in this episode
was just to let you know that there will
be a new team so Diggle is SpecOps
overseas there'll be some big WTF with
his storyline that will cause him to
come back Thea is supposedly running the
mayor's office which sounds completely
implausible but Thea's arced this season
is more through the mayor's office than
it is through the Green Arrow stuff at
night in number four WTF is mister
terrific's big call-to-action like
everybody kind of
their call to action in this episode
move forward sharks that don't move
forward drown so everybody has to move
forward in this episode mr. terrific
gets the [ __ ] beat out of him so he's
like I don't want to feel that powerless
again so I think T's fears comic book
mr. terrific stuff is just around the
corner the number 3 kay-gee beast is
back in the flashbacks and he named
drops red star
so that's who Dolph Lundgren's Kovar
character is Kovar is red star in the
comics but they did like the producers
did say they weren't going straight to
comic book red star but they would
probably get there eventually it's just
like in the flashbacks Dolph Lundgren
will just be this huge badass big bad
for Oliver to defeat so in present at
you know number two WTF present-day Big
Bad is Prometheus but you also have
Tobias Church who's kind of like a mid
bad who gets a Bertinelli shout outs
everybody's like wait a minute is that
teasing Huntress is she going to be
coming back big maybe on that this
season they haven't said anything about
hunters coming back but Stephen Amell
did say that his dream team arrow did
have Huntress and Deathstroke on it and
we know that Deathstroke is coming back
for that hundredth episode so we'll see
about that but Tobias Church in
present-day is consolidating crime in
the city in prometheus is kind of like
an evil version of season 1 Oliver just
dropping bodies left and right
undermining the stuff that mayor Oliver
Queen is doing so maybe he knows that
Oliver is the green arrow because he
says the green arrow is mine so it
sounds like he knows Oliver secret and
then everybody's wondering like who is
prometheus is it Tommy is this a big
flashpoint twist I think it's somebody
who is specific to the list so the names
that they read off in the flashbacks
from the list were all people that
either Oliver killed or in the case of
Frank Bertinelli that Helena killed so
it's people on the list that have died
so I think that's what's tying this to
prometheus
so he or she is somebody who is related
to or connected to somebody that was on
the list and is dead now because of what
Oliver did during season 1 so when
you're thinking about who prometheus
might be just keep your theorizing
within that scope people that are tied
to the list specifically especially
season 1 but number 1 WTF laurels
promise is revealed so it's kind of like
a mess
thing where she says don't let me be the
last canary so it's kind of like she's
telling him to form the new team but the
meta thing about canary is is that she
could be talking about actual canary
like somebody to take up the mantle of
black canary don't let me be the last
black canary and don't let me be the
last canary in the coalmine
so coal miners would use Canaries like
as an early detection warning signal for
when hardcore [ __ ] was going down so
that's kind of like the new team aspect
of that promise make sure you form a new
team but you can take that new version
of black canary with a grain of salt I
don't think that anybody's going to
become the black canary any time soon
but the other co showrunner Wendy
miracle said something weird in an
interview and it may have been
misinterpreted or she may have just been
making a turn of phrase when she said
Laurel was returning but she made it
sound like she was coming back to the
show alive in present day so it's like
wait a minute that doesn't make any
sense that's not what you said at all
last season so very confusing as to
what's going on with Laurel based on
what they've said but for now the only
time I think that Laurel is going to
show up in present day is either part of
a legends of tomorrow plotline which is
actually premiering next week or two
it's going to be earth to Laurel black
siren during the hundredth episode
because it seems like there's a bunch of
earth to stuff happening during the big
four night crossover like we're going to
see earth to Robert Queen who is the
green arrow of that earth so that's like
a completely separate thing that'll be
episode 8 we got to meet the new team
next week so we'll focus mostly on that
stuff for now but let me know what did
you think about the episode new trick
arrow parachute arrow they have to have
at least one new trick arrow every year
boxing-glove arrow still my favorite but
the most comic book ii thing i totally
love this part of the episode but it
wasn't the biggest because the big
action set piece was really cool but the
most comic book ii twist was tobias
church capturing mayor Oliver Queen as
bait for the green arrow oh I don't
think he's coming I think he's pretty
tied up right now
that's like the most comic boogie thing
ever it was totally great I love it when
they do that every once in a while but I
definitely like the dynamic I feel like
they've course-corrected on a lot of the
so penis from last season they're
definitely going hardcore season one in
terms of the way they construct the
episode
in the narrative this season so if
you're a big fan of arrow seasons 1 & 2
I feel like season 5 is where you should
get back on if you've stopped watching
so really high there's going to be way
more crossover stuff happening next week
- because Felicity is going to show up
during the episode of the flash where
Barry is like oh my god I changed
everything because of flashpoint
so she'll show up there I would expect
the same type of small crossovers to be
happening but for the big hundredth
episode so what's going to happen is is
next week obviously flash and arrow are
coming back for episode 2 but Supergirl
is premiering on Monday and then legends
of tomorrow is premiering on Thursday so
I'll just remind everybody with the
schedule is when I post my next flash
video because there is a flash trailer
video that I'll do in a little while so
we got new Luke Cage coming New York
Comic Con is happening so a whole bunch
of stuff is going to drop this weekend
be sure to subscribe to get everything
but congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Elliot R King you win a
$20 Amazon gift card so there is a new
round of the DC giveaway that starts now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video
so I'll remind everyone about the DC
giveaways when I post DC videos so next
video will probably be that flash
trailer then I have some loot cage that
I want to post and then we'll see like
what starts dropping at New York Comic
Con they just announced a big Wolverine
stuff so a lot of comic book stuff
happening Marvel and DC this week while
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for my flash episode 1 video
and you can click here for my Iron Fist
teaser trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight